vampires without sparkly skin finally
please be good Daybreakers okay so
vampire movies as of late have become
soft no that's not the word what's the
word I'm looking for
oh yeah lame I mean vampire movies went
from being the most badass stories ever
vampires vs. vampire hunters the
apocalypse is coming hardcore awesome -
but I am pumped to say we ring in 2010
with the return of the sweet vampire
movie
no Daybreakers was really interesting
from the get-go because usually in
vampire stories vampires remain hidden
in the night vastly outnumbered by the
human beings 99% of which don't even
believe that vampires exist they're
known only in myth and legend except for
like the five people chosen to hunt them
straight up Castlevania but in
Daybreakers vampires are the dominant
species on the planet 95% of the human
race have become vampires and the
handful of humans that remain are either
on the run or in facilities being farmed
for blood yeah it is a bloodsuckers
world out there but is the great
philosopher blade once told us a world
of all suck heads
yeah well it's bad already said
something like that because with the
lack of humans the blood well is running
dry and when vampires are deprived of
blood they go from civil upper class
vampires to the vampires in from dusk
till dawn
yeah demonic vampire gargoyles not a
pretty outcome and I really liked how
they touched on the economic backlash of
the blood supply dwindling in this movie
usually a movie like this wouldn't touch
on that but this one does like okay the
blood supply dwindles vampires start
becoming demonic vampire gargoyles the
hope for a blood substitute from the
company supplying the blood looks bleak
then other companies pull their stock
from that company blood prices skyrocket
average vampire citizens now can't
afford blood which means they turn into
demonic vampire gargoyles and then the
cycle repeats
I found that cool basically the vampires
are in a shitstorm but Willem Dafoe who
let's face it looks more vampire than
human on a good day was once a vampire
but then mysteriously got cured and thus
Ethan Hawke's race against time to find
a cure ensues as for the characters I
really like the characters in this movie
I mean Ethan Hawke's character obviously
doesn't like being a vampire he's living
in a world he knows his doomed working
tirelessly to come up with a blood
substitute before from dusk till dawn
happens to the entire world
old-looking you say he's a vampire with
a heart for humanity he was good I liked
him willem dafoe just straight-up owns
he's the sarcastic really chill X
vampire who might just be the hope for
Humanity and he steals every scene he's
in just try to find a scene he's in that
he doesn't steal I dare ya
sam neill was perfect as the corporate
douche bloodsucker that you can pretty
much find in most corporations these
days and surprisingly the other
characters provide enough weight to keep
the situation's coming the interest
alive and a shitstorm flowing is it
strange that I found Ethan Hawke and
Claudia car vans chemistry although
mostly professional a hundred times more
interesting than what's-his-face and
what they're nuts just saying in the end
if you like vampire flakes you're gonna
love this movie
it has a good mix of old-school vampire
lore with a new-school feel and
new-school world
I mean vampires rule the world that's
interesting this movie has more than
enough to keep you interested and keep
you going you like blood it's got it
fangs got it exploding bodies yep
popping heads course spontaneous
combustion mmm-hmm
sparkly skin in the sunlight no this is
a vampire movie after all but if you
don't like vampire movies I still think
you'll like this movie enough but watch
it it's a good movie I hope it gets a
sequel
oh and as a little bonus about 2/3 to
3/4 of the way through the movie yeah
ethan hawke looks just like Han Solo he
has the hair he has the outfit he is Han
Solo check it out it's hilarious